[Music]
connected with his madness and the inner
balance of someone who can look very
cute and sweet and childlike but is
hiding something
terrifying and when I saw Bill for the
first time I saw it immediately what are
you going yet his performance was
brilliant because he was on that birch
it meant a lot for me that Andy
responded to whatever I did and because
of that we did how kind of a connection
from the beginning he trusted me and I
trusted him so we kind of both figured
out what the character was together and
then I could really go for it and know
that I was in good hands well Downey
apart from being an incredibly talented
actor he has amazing control or body and
some weird control of his face in
particular I do this thing with my lip
it's a thing that I've been doing since
I was a little kid and I always wanted
to bring this like lip thing into a
character so of going into the audition
I was like like I wanted to like use the
face and like play around with that I
wanted to give Pennywise a wall die
because in my vision of the character
sometimes his eye would fall off and
something that was very cute and sweet
turns into something much more
unsettling because he has that weird
balance so when I mentioned that I
wanted to do that digitally he said I
can do it I had kind of a lazy eye and I
can like make it go it was crazy because
well the chance is that the actor that
you cast can do that practically there
was like all these different things that
I've been meaning to put into a
character then this character appeared
not can I just kind of put all these
things together to make as much of a
weird disturbing performance as possible
egg boy
[Music]
you
[Music]